oh
god good morning hank it's tuesday you
know how like every email right now
begins i hope you're holding up okay
i i am not holding up okay but
actually there's no but to that sentence
like a lot of people i know with chronic
mental health problems i am having a
hard time we do however have to get
through this like we literally have to
so today i'd like to share some things
that are helping me get through right
now and i'm hoping in comments you'll
let me know about some things that are
helping you get through and then we can
learn from each other
and together we can get through better
and be encouraged okay let's start with
wind
lately i find it very helpful to go
outside i mean in line with local
restrictions and just like feel the wind
on my skin
this works when it's a barely
perceptible breeze or when it's like
gale force wind is just so
weird and wondrous and feeling it makes
me aware of my aliveness
also wind just reminds me that the earth
contains like a lot of air
and at a time when sharing air in the
narrowest sense
is very dangerous sharing air in the
largest sense
remains absolutely essential then
there's tv slash movies
youtube slash whatever we're gonna call
visual media in the future i've been
watching a lot of documentaries lately i
really enjoyed foosballers a movie about
high level foosball playing and also sue
kim's short film
the speedcubers both of which i guess
are about people obsessed with niche
sports which is kind of my genre
i think i just love stories about humans
making meaning where none inherently
exists like at a foosball table by the
way i am not a speedcuber but i can now
reliably solve a rubik's cube in under
three minutes i
love this thing i've found it very
helpful to pick up an activity that
occupies some of my mind without
requiring
all of it and rubik's cubes are kind of
like tetris or trail running in that
they put me into a
calm flow state that i really need at
the moment
also i really love the netflix show
connections hosted by latif nasser from
radiolab
whether he's talking about sewage or
dust the show gives me a feeling of
wonder and it also models how
intellectual inquiry happens for me like
making and finding connections is when
learning becomes exciting for me
while we're on the subject of latif
nasser i cannot recommend his radiolab
series the other latif
enough it is brilliant also i've been
listening to invisibilia and heavyweight
when i need to cry
which is often and i've found planet
money really helpful for understanding
the knock-on effects of the pandemic
and then there are books oh thank god
for books in hard times i like to return
to books i've loved in the past like i
recently
reread the bell jar and our copy is
sarah's copy from high school so i got
to see all her underlinings and notes in
the margins which
was just so lovely i also reread some
young adult novels i love including
jacqueline woodson's behind you which
made me cry so hard i
couldn't see the words on the page and e
lockhart's the disreputable history of
frankie landau banks which is maybe my
favorite boarding school novel ever
also while i always love the life's
library book club where nerdfighteria
reads books together while raising money
to fight maternal mortality
i really love it right now we just read
bernadine evaristo's brilliant novel
blonde roots and now we're reading paige
lewis's space struck which among many
other things is an exploration of
anxiety
and dread and it really makes me feel
less alone
i mean i've quoted this before in a vlog
with this video because it just so
perfectly describes how i feel
i feel as if i'm on the moon listening
to the air
hiss out of my space suit and i can't
find the hole
i'm the vice president of panic and the
president
is missing that's it i'm the vice
president of panic and the president is
definitely missing anyway if you want to
join us you can find out more about the
book club at life's librarybookclub.com
now that i've made this list one i feel
better too it occurs to me that watching
documentaries and reading in community
and even practicing the rubik's cube
are all ways of learning and listening
and these days that really is where i'm
finding meaning and comfort
in learning from others and listening to
others
even if from afar hank i'll see you on
friday